dozens of people have been killed in
uganda's capital kampala
since protests broke out on wednesday
they began after pop star
turned presidential candidate bobby wine
was arrested
he held a campaign rally in luonga
district just over a hundred kilometers
from the capital
as usual it attracted thousands of
supporters
many more than the limit of 200 allowed
on the kovid 19 restrictions
there was a violent riots by
activists of one of the political groups
in the
various towns in kampala and the police
intervened so
the dates were the result of
confrontation with the police
but bobby wine supporters didn't see it
like that
they think the government's trying to
stop him sweeping to victory
in presidential elections due in january
he's challenging president yoheri
masevani who's been in power for 34
years
after two days in jail he was charged in
court with breaking the covid prevention
rules
and released on bail this was in my
opinion meant
to break our results but i have news for
you mr ms7
and all those that work to sustain your
dictatorship
we cannot be broken you can increase on
our bodies
you can tear gas and paper spray our
bodies but you cannot touch our souls
we are not going to stop fighting for a
better uganda
four other opposition presidential
candidates have suspended their
campaigns
in protest against the actions of the
security forces
the government blamed the demonstrators
for rioting and attacking police
officers
police has a right to shoot you
and kill you if you reach a certain
level
of violence the elections are meant to
be held just under two months from now
it's not clear if the campaigns will
continue or how
but it is clear they've got off to a
violent start malcolm webb
al jazeera